what do you think about how the media  and everything that's going on is  handling Kanye West  I don't know man you know he's  apologetic you know Kanye West my  brother my family I'm not here to make  excuses or you know dig into his  situation  uh you know I support him and uh  you know some things could be taken out  of text obviously the same guy they use  for clout and they use to make clothes  and make money off  now they just drop them in embarrass  them publicly because  you know it's the same stories you know  same Toilet Man different [ __ ] is just a  lot of [ __ ] piled up you know and you  know when [ __ ] pile up it gets smelly  you know it gets stink gets stopped up  and it's you know somebody got a dress  it somebody got to be the plumber so I  command my brother yay and don't call  him Kanye call him yay you know I  commend my brother yay you know for  being so courageous  and uh consider it because it take a lot  of courage and uh  it's lit